the annual Mesquite hot air balloon
festival is happening January 27th
through the 29th it is an event that the
entire family will enjoy here to tell us
more as Christian adderson the assistant
general manager at Casablanca Resort and
Casino who are the sponsors of this next
segment welcome to the show hey thanks
JC thanks for having me on it's always
great having you on here you bring fun
to the show so what's happening with the
balloon festival absolutely we're going
to our 11th year the Mesquite higher
balloon festival and you know the
Casablanca Resort's a great host for
this event we have over 35 hot air
balloons launching Friday Saturday and
Sunday mornings weather permitting and
then on Friday and Saturday nights we
have our world famous night glow that
happened right at the Casablanca Resort
it's gorgeous up there how many hot air
balloons are we gonna have 35 this year
that's a lot of hot air balloons it is
you know when they when they'll get in
the air in the mornings you know with
all those balloons up in the air over
that Mesquite skyline behind the
Casablanca Resort it's not a better site
in the whole Southwest well I'm going to
argue that actually because it is sunny
seeing this balloons we're seeing them
right here what we're seeing here though
too is at night time time too and to see
those balloons light up and you have
what's it called the glow at night what
happens at night we do have the
nightclaw and that's going to be from
six to seven o'clock on Friday and
Saturday nights we have six heart blooms
that fill up and then we have another
eight that we call candlesticking and we
have a great DJ out there a bar so we
put some music we put on a fantastic
light show so bring the whole family
it's free to the public to attend come
see us at the Casablanca Resort and if
you've never been to a hot air balloon
festival there's there's a feeling it is
Majestic in the morning and it is a
feeling too at night when they're
lighting up in the sound of those
balloons going off do you guys need
volunteers to help out absolutely yeah
the volunteers are always welcome and
they can register on
casablancareesort.com and then come up
and volunteer we have them help out with
the balloon crew yeah helping them set
up in the morning help with that chase
crew and uh their integral part to the
event and all the volunteers that come
up make sure they get an event t-shirt a
pen and get to meet and get up close
some beautiful balloons is this is this
a competition between the two between
the balloonists yeah absolutely you know
every Festival a little bit different
and the Mesquite Harbor balloon festival
really is just a great visual appeal
come up I think the coolest thing about
our Festival is you get to get up and
close with the pilots in the morning you
know the whole Field's open to the
public they can walk right up to the
basket as they're filming up getting
ready to launch it yes and safety of the
nightclub they're those are Tethered to
the ground at night so the kids can
really get up close and they can get in
a basket on the ground and really enjoy
the whole festival and get the whole
feel of that hot air balloon festival it
is a great family event and it's so much
fun up there and I believe you guys have
won best of Las Vegas is it three years
in a row now yes a gold winner right
here the best destination which is true
they gotta get they got it right for
these three years how does that make you
feel it feels fantastic you know that
the support we get from the Vegas Valley
and the folks that come up and stay with
us you know we have great Hospitality we
have fantastic special events and our
amenities are unmatched from Catherine's
Steakhouse to the spa and the great
people of Vegas been great supporters of
us and we love to invite them every
weekend and even during the week to come
stay with us at the Casablanca Resort we
can go check out the hot air balloon
festival or you can make a weekend at it
absolutely that's the best way to go
because you get you get a chance to see
three different launches if you stay the
whole weekend two night clothes and
enjoy all the great Services amenities
at the Casablanca Resort has to offer
it's going to be so much fun did you say
earlier there's a DJ there's live music
there's entertainment happening in the
weekend too absolutely during that
nightclub we have we're bringing a DJ we
have a bar out there just to make that
scene even better a couple drinks in you
enjoy some great light show have the
kids out there just enjoy a great
evening at the Casablanca Resort it's a
great weekend I love it thank you for
joining us Christian we appreciate it
and thanks to the Casablanca Resort and
Casino for sponsoring this segment the
Mesquite hot air balloon festival is
happening January 27th through the 29th
for more information call
877-438-2929 or visit
casablancareesort.com